the coronavirus pandemic is causing a
mental health crisis
among the front line health care workers
one study found that 57 percent
57 percent have experienced acute stress
and 48 percent
exhibited depressive symptoms now the
doctors and the nurses tell us they've
been working relentlessly for months
and now they are dealing with new
challenges and fears as a number of
hospitalizations
hits a record high things are pretty
tough right now for us
our med surg beds are pretty much at
capacity
and then we have about 10 of our staff
that are out quarantined
so we're facing staff shortages it's
kind of an exercise in
system stress tolerance how much can we
take until the wheels fall off are you
seeing your hospital where you're
working being
overwhelmed with patients we're
certainly getting a major
influx we're having to manufacture new
places to put people we're looking at a
situation where icus are going to be
full
even if we can create physical beds we
just won't have the staff
that we need to be able to care for
people the way they need to be cared for
what is it like emotionally at this
point
healthcare workers are carrying an
enormous emotional burden and toll
from the last several months uh just the
level of
fatigue and accumulated trauma our
health care providers have faced
already we're at a point where people
should really be looking to replenish
themselves and instead of replenishing
themselves
they're climbing the highest part of the
mountain i think exhaustion is the
biggest
the nurses here are working a minimum of
four 12-hour shifts a week
and then on top of it having all the
schools be out so you're basically
working a 12-hour shift and
you're going home at night and trying to
homeschool your your children
and you're doing that day after day
after day
i think a lot of us now are are in kind
of for the lack of a word siege
mentality
where emotional considerations just kind
of get pushed aside for a while
it is fatigue beyond fatigue at the
point where we're
most worn down we actually have to do
something that is
exponentially probably going to be more
work than what we've done
and dealt with before and we can't stay
home and work from home
we show up every day and we do the best
we can but you still have to deal with
that mental toll it does take on you
that horrifying fear in the back of your
mind that
at some point people are just going to
die
because there's no place for them that
gives me pause
i do believe that there is this
reckoning with how vulnerable we all
are to the virus to the possibility of
being
overwhelmed by it and death i think is
something that i grapple with as a
doctor but it never became so
tangible until now what do you want
people to know
about how health care workers are
feeling going into
another surge no matter what we are here
and in the same way that we'll always be
here for you we also want
people to really do all the things we
know we can do to stop transmission
at the end of the day we're putting one
foot in front of the other and showing
up
every morning and that is 99 percent of
the battle
wow our senior medical correspondent dr
tara narula is following the effect
of the pandemic on the front line
workers and joins us now tara i remember
when you did a story like this
back in march it hadn't even been a
month i remember thinking god i never
thought of that before
how these people must be feeling who are
literally risking their lives to save
ours
so what is at stake for them right now
what is the biggest challenge for them
well gail you heard the fatigue is
certainly a challenge but it really is
this sense of being in a marathon
and it's just a relentless pace that
doesn't let up for all of these months
the concern that they're just going to
as dr nielsen said drown
under the weight of all of these
patients how are they going to take care
of them
but one of the other biggest challenges
is feeling like people still
aren't taking this seriously walking out
of the hospital seeing people not
wearing masks
in lines packed together waiting to get
into a bar and that's why many of them
have turned to
television or social media to tell those
personal stories thinking maybe that
will make an
impact this is what we're witnessing
inside the hospital
dr dillon in the piece telling us one of
the darkest moments for him
was telling two teenagers that their
father died in his icu
and then three days later that their
mother died all of this over the phone
without these kids being able to say
goodbye to their parents
to see them so these are the stories
that we hope will make an impact on
people so they take these mitigation
strategies seriously they must go nuts
when they walk around and see people
being so careless and reckless
i heard one doctor say it's like running
a marathon what you just said
and then being asked to do the ironman
right after that there's just no let up
do they have any silver linings do you
see any silver linings for them
well certainly they talked about the
hope associated with a vaccine
and also hearing these survivor stories
and seeing survivors that gives them the
strength to keep going
they also talked about the camaraderie
being a silver lining that they really
bonded being in the trenches together
but as dr nielsen said to us there is a
light at the end of the tunnel
but it's a very long tunnel still gosh
tara thank you very much i think these
stories are so important to remind
people again
wear your mask